[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well dark Brandon does it again
Joe Biden delivers to the American
working people
[Music]
showing that he knows how to govern
and normalcy in democracy
seems to be coming back in style
I mean that's what we want right you
know our democracy
our economy being having some sort of
normal stability
I mean that's what you want right or do
you want or do you want people like
Lindsey Graham and Ron DeSantis running
your economy Lindsey Grammy wants to
take your [ __ ] Freedom away on a
federal level you talk about big
[ __ ] government baby
Lindsey Graham wants to take away your
freedom on a federal level Ron DeSantis
is trafficking humans
while Joe Biden is actually waking up
putting his [ __ ] shoes on
and doing the job that the American
people need done
he reaches a deal with the Railroad
Union
to stop the
the the
the toting of products all across the
country the economy
folks this isn't just about trains
rolling on Rails this is about products
moving services health care for those
workers who do that job real [ __ ]
American Working Class People
not not [ __ ]
Rich [ __ ]
not Elites these are real people who do
real jobs lunchbox work want lunch box
workers
they go to work every single day
and they do a hard job
and they should get paid
a decent wage
they shouldn't go broke because of a
[ __ ] medical bill
they should be able to send their
children to college
help send their grandchildren to college
and retire at a decent [ __ ] age
it's not too [ __ ] complicated
why normalcy and stability and democracy
works
and fascism all it does is divide and
destroy
what is hilarious about Greg Abbott and
Ron DeSantis trafficking humans and I
I'm saying it's hilarious
the places that these folks are going
these humans are going they're human
beings
the places that they're going
are
giving them jobs
making them integral parts of the
economy
Greg Abbott and Ron DeSantis doesn't
want migrants to be part of their of
their economy because they're [ __ ]
fascist
they'd much rather send a message to all
the [ __ ] bigots out there
by shipping brown people because that's
that's what they see it as
[ __ ] doubt me
it's a it's it's it's a message to all
white supremacists out there that these
people are not [ __ ] human
that they're pieces of [ __ ] meat and
we can just send them anywhere we want
and I I know what that you've seen it in
the threads already today
well it's the Democrat areas that want
these people
matter of fact they're putting them the
work making them an integral part of the
economy there's Help Wanted signs
everywhere
there's Help Wanted signs everywhere
there's jobs available the economy's
rolling baby
what do you think inflation is do you
think inflation is the economy being
depressed
a recession no it's the opposite of
recession that's what it is
and it's difficult
if you don't have someone who cares
about the American working people
and this morning last night and this
morning overnight
the president of the United States Joe
Biden
does his [ __ ] job and delivers for
the people who voted for him and the
people who didn't vote for him
understand that
that Joe Biden didn't do this for blue
States and Democrats he did it for
America and our economy
there are plenty of people plenty of
people
who are [ __ ] mug King America First
Nazi sycophants
who are gonna go vote for a bunch of
[ __ ] Republicans who want to take
their freedoms away and want to destroy
their economy that are going to benefit
from this deal that was made overnight
with the Railroad Union
that the administration
helped get to
they don't get it they're [ __ ]
boneheads of course the moglodytes don't
get this they won't they'll be like oh
this is such a terrible deal it's so bad
Joe Baden so bad at making deals and
delivering for the American people yeah
okay good luck with that narrative good
[ __ ] luck good luck with your gas
price [ __ ] good luck with your
inflation [ __ ] good [ __ ] luck
that's right the inflation stuff the
market oh the market crashing it's all
[ __ ] it's all nonsense [ __ ]
[ __ ]
there's no sign there's no real sign no
real indication that we're going to be
dipping into recession even as interest
rates rise so they can try to draw us
into a recession
oh
so don't believe the [ __ ]
stick with democracy
and yeah democracy is [ __ ] difficult
we've said that a hundred thousand times
here on the Tony Michaels podcast
democracy is [ __ ] hard that's the way
it's actually designed is that you have
to actually do the hard work
that's the whole point
is for us all to do the [ __ ]
job
they always say oh Liberals are lazy and
Liberals are weak what is weaker and
what is more lazy
then Ron DeSantis
looking at a bunch of human beings
because of the color of their skin and
where they come from to say well just
put them on a plane and ship them what
make it someone else's problem it seems
pretty [ __ ] lazy to me
pretty [ __ ] weak that he can't do his
[ __ ] job and figure out a way to make
these people part of the the society and
the economy in Florida
I'm sure there's plenty of [ __ ] help
wanted signs down in Florida
I'm sure there's plenty of private
businesses for-profit capitalists who
would love to have Labor
and Ron DeSantis is like no I'm weak
because I'm a fascist
and I'm lazy because I'm an
authoritarian so I don't want to
actually deal with the with the issue at
hand
I'm just gonna put it on someone else
and I'm literally gonna human traffick
these people to another state across the
border
whoosh the contrast is Stark folks
but it's up to you
to engage in your democracy and get
everyone around you to understand that
contrast
it's up to you
you can talk about Sunday football on
Sunday with your your friends your
community your family
and just not oh man I really don't want
to bring up
this economy thing oh
it's kind of oh the or you can do the
thing that you're supposed to do and
engage in your democracy and tell those
[ __ ] what's going on
now Ron DeSantis is not focused on the
economy in Florida he doesn't give two
shits about the economy in Florida not a
[ __ ] he doesn't care doesn't give a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] was
he was pimping against
the infrastructure bill you remember
that you remember the infrastructure
bill
that dark Brandon got passed
providing much needed financing
to lift our [ __ ] infrastructure
out of a decrepit State and and create
jobs
he was against that
and now that he can easily get the check
he doesn't do the hard part he doesn't
do the hard part which is like I don't
know actually helping get the
legislation passed he does the easy part
he prints these big checks and holds
these big [ __ ] these big [ __ ]
ceremonies where he passes the money he
was against
to help Florida and Joe Biden did that
[ __ ] not Ron DeSantis not [ __ ] Maga
Republicans not fascists
pro-democracy people made that happen
they did the hard work because they're
not [ __ ] lazy Liberals are not lazy
Liberals are not [ __ ] weak I'm sick
of that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] fascist [ __ ] are a bunch
of weak lazy bastards
Well Ron DeSantis and Trump will fix
everything I'll just I'll just see what
they say
oh he'll he'll post something and I'll
I'll I'll copy what he says I don't have
a real original thought in my brain so
I'll just do whatever turn up and
DeSantis and gray Babbitt and Ted Cruz
says oh and Rand Paul and Lindsey Graham
I'll just listen to what they say and
I'll do that
that makes me that makes me real strong
makes me a real man
the [ __ ] out of here with that nonsense
Stark difference and everyone on Twitter
this morning is paying attention to the
human trafficking that Ron DeSantis and
Greg Abbott are participating in they're
human traffickers
but folks
Joe Biden
did his work and helped the American
working people how here's how you
message you remember how we say
politicize everything I mean [ __ ]
everything politicize it you want to win
you want to have a democracy
you want to say in our government
because it's [ __ ] ours baby it's our
government
you gotta learn how to message and the
message is while Rhonda santis and Greg
Abbott are human trafficking people
and hurting their economy Joe Biden is
delivering for the American working
class
he's delivering for the American economy
because this isn't just going to help
American working people oh it definitely
will help American working people not
just the people
who work on the railroad
it's as if it's as if people who
self-proclaim themselves capitalists
don't even understand how the economy
and capitalism even [ __ ] works
trickle down trickle down oh really so
what you're telling me is is you believe
the nonsense about trickle-down
economics when it comes to taxes but you
don't understand actual trickle-down
economics
where everything is integral everything
is weaved into a web you shut down the
railroad you [ __ ] hurt the economy is
what you do
and those union workers should demand
should demand that they don't go broke
because of a medical bill that they have
a decent [ __ ] wage
or shut that [ __ ] down
they should demand that they should
demand that everywhere at all of it
everywhere
[ __ ] the one percent [ __ ] them
but this is good for companies too
don't get it twisted I mean this isn't
about
hurting the rich this this [ __ ] deal
is gonna help the rich they're God
they're goddamn highways which is
railroads to to move their product
into markets in and out of markets is
now gonna stay open
they were worried gonna have to figure
out how the [ __ ] they're gonna move
their products
think about it folks
this is really easy to talk to these
dumb [ __ ] you just gotta stop
talking about statistics you gotta stop
talking about [ __ ] worrying about
unemployment rates and words like
Universal [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's really
easy to message this stuff
Ron DeSantis is trafficking humans Joe
Biden is putting Americans to work
what you would you rather have do you
want autocracy are you do you want a
democracy because it's a stark
difference
do you want Lindsey Graham whose main
concern main concern
I mean he just this is important [ __ ] to
Lindsey Graham who doesn't have a uterus
isn't isn't [ __ ] married does not
have children
he has no daughters
he's really concerned about uteruses and
women's bodies even though
he doesn't have one maybe
hell from the way it pray it sounds he
doesn't even like women
you know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
listen Lindsey Graham said in front of a
microphone vote for Republicans we will
take away your freedom vote for
Democrats they will protect your freedom
that's your [ __ ] choice
how how is this difficult to message
this Lindsey Graham delivered this on a
platter Ron DeSantis Greg Abbott is
delivering this on a [ __ ] platter
for democracy
people still with a half a brain left if
you put it to him in a certain form and
fashion will realize the difference
and I'm not talking about your [ __ ]
Trump humping relative your Trump hump
and Uncle Uncle Carl
I'm talking
about people who don't normally pay
attention to politics like you do
they don't pay attention they get sick
of it really they're sick of hearing the
word Trump
they're sick of it they would just wish
he would [ __ ] go away
but they still may go vote Republican
which is definitely not going to make
him go away
see you after
you know slightly move them in the
direction
of democracy
they believe in it don't worry about it
I'm telling you
even though they don't know much about
it much about politics they probably
don't really even know
who some of these folks are
but they care about their way of life
trust me they care about their way of
life
they care about the condition
not just of their way of life now but
what it could be
they give a [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
but all you gotta do
is engage
engage with them and you have to go
[ __ ] vote I know you knew that anyone
here
at the Tony Michaels podcast understands
that you have to go vote you must use
the ballot as a hammer and what I mean
by that is we gotta we gotta pile
mountains of votes against these
[ __ ] mountains of votes we
can't just win by a little bit
we have to
absolutely
unequivocally
pile them
under colossal amounts of votes
it is super important even if you're in
a blue state
and it's a slam dunk don't don't don't
get it twisted
you still must engage you still must
make sure your registration's there
ask other folks are you registered after
you say did you hear Ron DeSantis is
trafficking humans and banning Book
Fairs down in Florida
no he is yeah are you registered to vote
there you go right there boom
pretty [ __ ] easy did you hear Joe
Biden
made sure the railroad stayed open so
that we could receive the product that
we want and need
I didn't hear that yeah and Ron DeSantis
is flying flying brown people on planes
to Marshall Vineyard and he thinks it's
cool
what yeah you might want to go register
to vote and make sure your
registration's good because this is the
contrast
so it's up to you and and again to
engage in your democracy there's all
sorts of ways to engage
you can you can tweet you can send out
message on failed share this show with
anyone you know
they may not like the f word but yeah
[ __ ] them
share this I I I'm telling you they
won't be so offended once they listen
they'll know that there's more than just
the [ __ ] on the show
share it
you can text for a campaign
you can call you can write letters you
can do postcards you can knock on doors
for a campaign
that weather's getting nicer out there I
know it's been hot boy it's been hot
but we need to hit the streets
you can also donate that's one of the
most important things if you've got a
little extra change find that campaign
and give them five dollars ten dollars
whatever it is
because that money that pro-democracy
money is going to pull democracy over
the line and folks we're all on message
we are on message they are they are
[ __ ] in disarray they don't know
rather to talk about human traff
bragging about their human trafficking
bragging about guns being everywhere
which the American people don't want or
they're I'm telling you this afternoon
they're going to talk about how this is
a bad deal that the American economy is
back on track no pun intended with the
Railroad Union deal
foreign
s are going to talk about they're going
to hand us more more platter more
democracy platter
the slam dunk them in November and it's
gonna be tough it's not gonna be [ __ ]
easy because they don't want to make it
easy
they don't want to make it easy they're
really working hard to make sure your
vote don't count because they know
they know when you go vote they are
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're scared they're frightened we got
them on the run and Joe Biden's not
going to stop doing his job that's a
beautiful part
dark Brandon is here to stay speaking of
dark Brandon did you guys notice we have
dark Brandon merch here at the Tony
Michaels podcast this is an exclusive
design at the Tony Michaels podcast go
to store.they Tony michaels.com
get your dark Brandon exclusives
designed t-shirts hoodies
coffee mugs and stickers
store not the Tony michaels.com we love
the dark Brandon I love dark Brandon I
love that we stole this away from them
and I love that he's not going to stop
working for democracy he's not he's not
going to stop working for democracy
folks he's not gonna do it
he's gonna keep going
you can trust
that Joe Biden is gonna get up in the
morning and put his [ __ ] shoes on and
work for the American people what else
does he have to lose
this is his last job this is it
this is his this is his retirement
could have retired he could have went to
Delaware and retired
and not had to put up with the nonsense
not had to do deals with stay up all
night doing deals with railroads
trying to have to figure out how to get
around these Maga Republicans that
absolutely won't make a vote on any
legislation that's good for the American
people but he's doing it and he's gonna
keep doing it he's not gonna stop he's
not gonna quit he's not gonna go [ __ ]
golfing the next the next two years
after the midterm every [ __ ] day
waste a ton of the taxpayers money going
golfing
he's not gonna sit and tweet all goddamn
day on the [ __ ]
he's not going to try to figure out how
to cover up for the last lie with the
next lie he's just gonna do the job
and I'm not saying Joe Biden is some
kind of super here maybe dark Brandon is
he might be that alter ego
you know the anti-hero
but Joe Biden's not some superhero
but In This Moment In This Moment
he is doing what is right for the
American people in the American economy
and if you watch his accomplishments if
you've been watching his accomplishments
spell the American people not the rich
not rich people with tax cuts when you
ask trumpers when you ask them what did
Trump do that was so great oh well he um
he had really low gas prices during the
pandemic when no one was driving in the
market Tanked and crude oil was
less than zero dollars
a barrel he did that oh really so he
tanked the economy
he raised he he raised taxes on the
middle class and he cut taxes on the
rich oh really so he raised your taxes
but he cut taxes on the the one percent
well yeah that's a great thing okay yeah
what did he do for the American people
all the promises that he made about coal
and factories he [ __ ] them and he told
them to go get [ __ ]
Joe Biden actually worked for the chips
Act
he pulled coronavirus relief over the
line to relieve Pete to give people
relief from inflation in the child tax
credit
and made sure that school lunches were
free which state that's what we should
just do we should just do that we should
I don't know feed children sounds pretty
Christian to me I'm not a Christian but
God damn
sounds sounds like that book would
endorse feeding children
we should do that we should do that but
we're gonna have to elect Democrats
he
he passed the pact Act
he made sure that veterans
who were poisoned because of burned pits
because of the service they did to their
country inadvertently
have been riddled with disease and
cancer who were dying and suffering
he delivered that Democrats did Joe
Biden helped push that over the line
and make sure that our veterans receive
the health care they deserve
for the ailments that they got while
they were serving us
the list goes on and on and on folks now
the contrast
the contrast there this big list of
accomplishments that Joe Biden has done
go to all the criminal indictments that
Trump's about to face
Sean Hannity played it the other day on
the show it was beautiful oh my God Sean
handy what a service he put together a
great list of all the criminal
investigations
all the crime that Trump has done
showed us hey look look at all the crime
this guy's doing
Joe Biden's got a list just as long of
accomplishments for the American people
not for Joe Biden not for Joe Biden
these aren't things that benefit him
these are things that benefit the
American people it's not it's not things
that benefit his [ __ ] donors the
donor class hell they give to
Republicans the donor class has given up
on Democrats
because all Democrats want to do is make
sure that the American people have a
decent [ __ ] wage they got decent
[ __ ] Health Care they can afford
education
and that they don't go broke because of
taxes
that's what they want nope
that's not what these [ __ ] rich
people want they do not want the
American working class to understand
what what important labor is they don't
want them to have a decent [ __ ] wage
because they have to pay it
they do not want them to not go broke
because of a medical bill because
they'll have to pay the [ __ ] medical
bill
and they definitely don't want you to
have a damn decent education they don't
want you to have a decent education an
affordable decent education they want
you to spend your entire life paying off
a student loan that has high interest on
it
where the government's making all kinds
of money off you and your education and
your job your career your your your
contribution to the economy that's what
Republicans want
so go engage in your democracy do it now
do it loud and do it proud [ __ ] them
[ __ ] em
everyone stick around we're gonna do the
shitless Roundup we got Rachel Dr Rachel
bittickoff are on today she's gonna come
talk about this railroad deal but the
other thing I uh she's going to talk
about is some of these midterms we're
getting really close here now we had a
political strategist Jeffrey Timmer on
yesterday and Rachel bidikoff for today
Sherry Jacobus was on Monday so we're
piling up the guest here to bring to you
exactly what you need to do and get out
there and make sure that we have safe
secure elections and we get to turn out
[ __ ] we need a huge turnout
that's how we're going to turn this
around and make sure we send these
moglodytes these Maga Republicans these
America First fascists back underneath
their rocks don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them Buckle [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking through the break
[Music]
there's a lot of megalodites on the
Facebook feed that are really pissed off
about what I'm saying good good [ __ ] em
that's all I gotta say welcome to the
Tony Michaels podcast where we do the
shitlist Roundup we surf the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends we're gonna
watch some great video today uh what we
don't have Gabe joining us and he's he's
traveling he's going to his uh they're
opening up a new George Soros deep State
bunker somewhere and he's uh he's gotta
go
he's gotta go help dig the I don't I I
don't know actually exactly what he's
doing but he is he is traveling
um so he won't be joining us today
but he will sort of join us tomorrow no
he'll he won't be here tomorrow but
he'll you'll see him tomorrow because
what happened is we have bone end of the
week every single Friday you know this
you know we have
the bone end of the week every single
Friday and Gabe was not gonna be here so
what we did is we put the poll out early
we recorded it yesterday after the show
so tomorrow we will play in the second
hour as always as promised the bonehead
of the week in the second hour of the
Friday show so tomorrow and we got a
great it was a great bone-in it's a
little it's kind of long longer than
normal
but we add a lot of boneheads to get to
and a lot of stuff we needed to show we
needed to break down a few things and
get some detail in there
so it uh it worked out really good so
you will see Gabe tomorrow he won't be
here it'll be a recording
but we did we did do a recording of
bonehead of the week because we do not
want to let up on democracy and bonehead
of the week boy you talk about you could
talk about engaging in your democracy
making sure you know who these
[ __ ] are Point them out and go
yep yep yep yep yep oh he's a fascist oh
he's a bonehead yep he's a Nazi it's
really easy that's what you do you have
to mock these people
you have to point them out daylight is
the best disinfectant now this morning
is going to show that with this contrast
on Twitter you have Ron DeSantis
trending because he's a human trafficker
Greg Abbott as well and then Joe Biden
is trafficking capitalist products for
the American people for the American
working class creating jobs
making sure that the economy stays open
oh [ __ ]
oh man that's I mean I I'm not making
this [ __ ] up
that's that's what it is this morning
that's the [ __ ] this morning Rhonda
santis flies a couple planes to Martha's
Vineyard Vineyard
of migrants
he thinks it's a great idea to look as
racist and bigoted as possible
Martha Vineyard welcomes them brings him
into church I guess I think that's you
know they actually they actually did the
you know um Christian thing
they did what what Jesus would do you
remember that wwjd where did that go
they used to wear those [ __ ]
bracelets a lot didn't they
remember that what would Jesus do
uh you know what Jesus would do he keep
the [ __ ] railroads open and he
wouldn't be flying planes of migrants
all the way across the country he'd be
helping them out trying to get him to be
integrated into the economy and into the
state make them productive make them
productive American people that's right
that's what [ __ ] Jesus would do the
American Jesus
[ __ ] Rhonda scientist you people are
brainwashed you're [ __ ] delusional
you white Christian nationalists get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] all
right let's do this let's surf the
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends is here
in just under 30 minutes we're gonna
have Dr Rachel bittick offer my favorite
you know this she is my favorite
political strategist number one number
one [ __ ] Dr Rachel bittickoff
are here in less than 30 minutes so
let's do this let's surf the Tweety
tweets
and trendy Trends start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh the segment where we serve the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends all across the
interwebs and we got a lot of stuff to
get to today so let's not waste much
time here let's get to the uh the Tweety
tweets and trenches the one thing I do
want to show you here
um is the video real quick of Joe Biden
we're gonna really piss off the mongolo
knights that are in the uh the chat here
um by showing them what it looks like to
be a [ __ ] real president of the
United States he's working for the
American working people
here we go
um there it is okay we got that
yeah I'm by myself today and I'm Gabe
with me so you unfortunately you don't
get to see uh my co-host Gabe Sanchez
but Rachel Rachel bittickoffer is going
to join us here in just a little bit but
let's let's watch this video
um the Pres the working president of the
United States not the gulfing president
of the United States come out and uh and
tell the American working people hey
these people worked hard the unions
worked hard the company's worked hard
the negotiators worked hard
and we try to facilitate this deal to
make sure that the American working
people stayed at work and the economy
stayed open listen
well good morning everyone
as you might guess I am very pleased to
announce a tentative labor agreement
between that has been reached between
the railroad workers and the railway
companies this agreement is a big win
for America
and for both in my view
I want to thank the lead negotiators and
the from the labor movement the brother
of locomotive Engineers the trainman
International Association of sheet metal
and air and Rail and transportation
workers union and the other labor unions
and Gates and this is a win for tens of
thousands of rail workers and for their
dignity and the Dignity of their work
it's a recognition of that during these
early dark uncertain days of the
pandemic they showed up so every
American could keep going they worked
tirelessly through the pandemic to
ensure that families and communities got
the deliveries they needed during these
difficult few years
because of the labor Grant
those rail workers will get better pay
24 wage increase over the next five
years
improved working conditions peace of
mind around their Health Care by capping
the cost that workers will have to pay
and it's about the right to go to a
doctor or stay healthy and make sure
you're able to have the care you can
afford it's all part of this agreement
they earned and deserve these benefits
and this is a great deal for Mozart in
my view the agreement is also a victory
for Railway companies and I want to
thank the lead negotiators from the
railway the National Railway labor
conference and our major rail companies
these companies also played a uh a
critical role in keeping America moving
during the pandemic and that's not
hyperbole is a fact
with disagreement railroad companies
will be able to retain and recruit
workers they'll be able to continue to
operate effectively as a vital piece of
our economy but really the backbone of
the economy I have as visual image of
rails being the backbone I mean
literally the backbone of the economy so
I thank the unions and Laurel Cummings
for negotiating in good faith came up
for 20 straight hours to that
negotiation and uh and for sticking with
it especially over the last few days in
fact the negotiators here today I don't
think they've been to bed yet
besides together when we reached an
agreement you reached an agreement that
will keep our critical rail system
working and avoid disruptions of our
economy and I'm grateful grateful for
the members of administration to work
tirelessly on both sides to help get
this done I especially want to thank
labor secretary Marty Walsh card
carrying Union member in the first union
labor secretary in decades first time
[Applause]
disagreement is validation validation
what I've always believed unions and
management can work together can work
together for the benefit of everyone
they're traveling now uh a number of
them up but I want to thank secretary
Transportation Pete footages and
agriculture secretary Tom vilsack we're
deeply involved along with uh I want to
thank Deputy labor secretary Julie Sue
Director of National Economic Council
Brian deese and the deputy National
director of Labor Celeste trade for this
commitment and hard work to the American
people this agreement can avert a
significant damage that any shutdown
would have brought our nation's rail
system is the backbone of our supply
chain everything you rely on it's hard
to realize everything from clean water
to food to gas to every day I mean
liquefied natural gas to everything
every good that you need received on a
rail getting delivered to where it needs
to go
with unemployment still in their record
lows and signs of progress and lowering
costs this agreement allows us to
continue to rebuild a better America
with an economy that truly works for
working people and their families today
is a win and I'm meeting sincerely a win
for America I want to thank you all for
getting this done both business and
labor thank you thank you thank you and
may God protect our troops thank you so
much
okay there's the president of the United
States
um I'm gonna point something out we have
uh fake Gabe over on Facebook and why we
were playing this he's got a few
comments here this is the delusional
[ __ ] that they post over on Facebook and
any of these threads and I welcome fake
gabier I like to have I like having Gabe
watching the show because eventually
folks eventually fake Abe will pluck his
head out of his ass if he watches this
show enough and he realizes exactly what
we're saying is not we're not weak
liberals aren't weak liberals deliver
for democracy they deliver for the
American economy okay that that's what
they do now I want I want to point
something out Gaby says this he says did
you all enjoy the CPI report on
inflation as Biden was touting the IRA
he's talking about the inflation
reduction act inflation actually
increased okay Gabe I've been saying
this for a long time and I don't know
maybe you need to turn the [ __ ]
volume up
but the opposite of inflation is
recession dummy
really what you need to do is you need
to learn how a capitalist economy works
you need to learn the fundamentals of it
and then and then you can go to the CPI
report and understand what the CPI
report actually says about the economy
and what the inflation reduction act
will do to change that CPI report
because the inflation has been going on
since the pandemic
see the inflation reduction Act was just
passed so just like you're [ __ ]
touting oh gas prices going up Joe Biden
made gas prices go up and now they're
going down because the administration
and the Democrats who are working for
the American people did [ __ ] to get that
done to make sure that the supply chains
were back for crude oil and gasoline to
drop your price at the pump
and now you're seeing the effects of
that [ __ ] dummy so just wait just
wait for that CPI report when this
inflation reduction act kicks in we'll
talk again Gabe don't stop watching man
don't stop watching a fake Gabe also has
another comment which I love this is how
you uh decouple these people if you want
to know when you go to your family
Barbecue and your Uncle Earl is saying
dumb [ __ ] that he got off Facebook like
Gabe does and Gabe says so Biden knew
this a month ago yeah he did know this a
month ago and they've been negotiating
the entire [ __ ] time and they got it
done in the last hour do you know what
Republicans would do Gabe do you know
what the people the fascists that you
would vote for because you don't
understand they don't have your interest
at heart do you know what they would do
fake Gabe what they would do is they
would make sure the railroad system
would shut down they [ __ ] hate unions
they [ __ ] hate American workers they
don't want to give them [ __ ] Health
Care in a decent [ __ ] wage [ __ ] those
people we want to make sure our donors
the elite the one percent
get all the [ __ ] money Gabe that's
what they want to do so they would shut
down the railroad and that's what Trump
would do he would shut down the railroad
to create a crisis to create a crisis
that way for months and months he could
go out and blame democrats for shutting
down the railroad
do you know what Joe Biden did he got up
he put his shoes on he did his [ __ ]
job for the American people and he got
the deal done
he got it done so the railroads won't
shut down so there is no crisis the
crisis is avoided because Democrats and
pro-democracy people did their [ __ ]
job that's why liberals aren't weak
that's why liberals aren't lazy
because they don't wait for something to
be broke to [ __ ] fix the problem they
see a problem a month ago they [ __ ]
fix it Gabe you're running right into
the point man
straight smack into it dummy
that's how you handle these folks and
Gabe keep watching really seriously I
like having you here
I do I like having you here
I like having these megalodites here
we've had Chris in here from the very
beginning and Chris he's probably still
in the chat somewhere on YouTube
Chris in everyone knows Chris in here
I like having these people with us
because eventually like Gabe says
they're going to understand that it's
not rhetoric what I'm saying is not
[ __ ] it's what the American people
know
it's simple [ __ ] facts it's easy to
understand this stuff it really is you
are so deluded by Facebook and your
propaganda that you don't understand
that you're making it way too
complicated you're over complicating
things when you're blaming brown people
when you're acting like people who have
certain genitalia are the problem with
the economy in our country when you
think when you think science is causing
us to to go back to the Middle Ages you
are some dumb [ __ ]
this this country is about just a few
things
just a few things and most of them are
America pie type [ __ ]
the railroads the economy jobs education
a decent life a decent lifestyle
they don't want to be told what the [ __ ]
to do who the [ __ ] you can and can't
marry what religion you can and can't
have they don't want to be told that
they don't want that nonsense
so get with it Gabe I know you will stay
here stay tuned stay tuned and you will
know you will know that eventually
that eventually we are going we are
going to turn you around and pluck your
head out of your ass and we will we will
turn you into a great Fighter for
democracy we really will I'm telling you
folks we will do this okay let's go back
to the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends
here enough of uh knocking on Gabe
because we have some uh let's see what
do we have trending
what do we have trending here Mark
Meadows is trending did you know he's
cooperating with subpoenas yeah he's
handing over a bunch of information he's
going to lock up Donald Trump uh that's
another thing ooh baby that's that's
what we want Hugh Hewitt's in the news
this morning
yeah because he tweeted and I mean
you know he Hewitt is some [ __ ]
used to be on MSNBC and [ __ ] ain't like
he's some kind of moderate [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] here's why he heard tweets this
morning he says former president Trump
at least she got that right former he's
not the he's former told me oh my God
Trump spoke to him I wonder if he
recorded it would you speak to Trump at
all over the phone or even in person
without recording that [ __ ] no way no
way would I [ __ ] have a conversation
or even be in the same room as that
[ __ ] without having at some
court it's a type of recording device on
Jesus Christ
Trump told him this am so this morning
that everything he took
everything he took to Mar-A-Lago was
Declassified
and that he has done nothing wrong
in the connection with alternative
slates of electors he did not try to
commit a coup
and cannot be United as a result uh of
course again Hugh Hewitt did record this
conversation because almost everyone
would he said audio and transcript
will post soon
okay here's what this says if you want
to know what this says it says that the
Cheeto dust mobster knows everything he
took to Mar-A-Lago was a hundred percent
full stop classified all of it
all the [ __ ] that they're saying in that
list that's classified information it's
not Declassified that's what he's saying
here just all you got to do is look at
what Donald Trump says and it's the
[ __ ] opposite
he's he's telling you out loud uh he
says that Trump says that he has done
nothing wrong in connection with the
alternative slate of electors there's
proof out there that he's done wrong
that he committed crime that he tried to
overthrow our free and fair election he
tried to take your democracy away from
you by stealing it fraudulently with
fake electors
yeah he did that he participated in it
I don't know if he'll get his cell phone
taken at Hardee's but that's a question
that we will come to and then he says I
and he cannot be indicted as a result
you are such a dumb [ __ ]
you are a dumb [ __ ] because one
of these crimes that you're admitting to
here inadvertently with your projection
Cheeto dust mobster the classified
information at Mar-A-Lago you did that
[ __ ] after you were president dummy you
do not have the protection of the
presidency for you not to be indicted
this dumb son of a [ __ ] is gonna be
indicted and he's telling you out loud
Donald Trump is telling you out loud
that he's going to be indicted he says I
cannot be indicted as a result of me
committing crimes get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] Hue Hewitt your
Tweet sucks
your Tweet sucks I'm glad that you
recorded the Cheeto dust mobster saying
this stuff so we know the actual truth
and what I mean by that is the
projection of the opposite
that's the name of the game in
moglerville nowadays 100 projection uh
let's go to let's go back to the uh the
Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends here
let's see what else is trending did I
miss anything oh Don Lemon is trending I
didn't see that this morning what the
hell is he trending for
what do we got uh oh uh Justin CNN's has
New Morning Show
oh Don Lemon is going to be on the new
Morning Show I guess Oh yay what what
the f who gives a [ __ ] you guys still
watching CNN does anyone still watch
this garbage I mean besides to clip out
the [ __ ] fascists that are talking
over there and the nonsense so we can
keep track of them I mean you got it you
gotta pay attention to that [ __ ] I mean
there's there's some real real [ __ ]
people out there that are doing us a
service by watching this garbage and
then posting it on the internet so we
can see it
um so we know exactly what they're up to
I mean we got to keep track of these
things this is a democracy we can't be
lazy like a bunch of fascists and just
take take the word of whoever says
whatever oh yeah we'll take your word
for it like Gabe like fake Gabe over in
the uh Facebook Chat Jesus Christ fake
game okay let's see what else do we have
Trinity human beings is trending I could
only imagine why human beings is
trending
what do you think you think human beings
is trending because Ron DeSantis is
human trafficking he's a [ __ ]
trafficker
he's a he's an admitted trafficker like
he's admitting to it
he's like you got to him right out of
traffic those human beings
women children yeah damn right I traffic
him you [ __ ] ain't right I did
uh Ron DeSantis you are a special kind
of Nazi piece of [ __ ]
um your legal is trending now there
could be all kinds of reasons why this
could be illegal uh Rick Wilson says
here
a friend points out Rick Wilson or
excuse me Rick Wilson points out a
friend points out Ron DeSantis flew two
plane loads of illegal migrants from
Venezuela to Martha's Vineyard without
coordinating with DHS or and whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
oh God damn
oh he is a coyote so I got the thumbnail
wrong the thumbnail's wrong the
thumbnail's wrong
it's not it's not uh it's not okay so
the thumbnail's wrong he's not a
trafficker and Rick Wilson says he's a
coyote
um wow I I wonder if Rhonda Santos is
going to be part of the drug cartel
cartel before we reach the election I
don't know it's possible
um the governor's is trending and the
reason why Governors is trending is
because there's two Governors that are
trafficking humans not just Ron DeSantis
but Greg Abbott is trafficking humans as
well that's why Governors is trending
now let's see Mayo says here the
governors of Texas and Florida are human
traffickers you goddamn right they are
Mayo they don't care about human beings
unless they're white voters you they and
they they're white Republican voters I'm
gonna fix the Mayo's tweet there I love
Mayo Mayo's Mayo's a good buddy
a friend of the show you gotta go
you gotta go follow Mayo if you're not
already which you probably are
because her tweets are so on point on
point Thank you thank you Mo Mayo for
being so spicy okay let's see Floridians
uh Honduras you know this is all this is
all trending because
Ron DeSantis is a fascist piece of [ __ ]
uh of course that's why all this stuff
is trending uh let's see what we got um
the mark Meadows story let's go to the
mark Meadow story here sorry I'm going
so fast I'm by myself today
you know what Gabe you know it's a much
slower Pace because we kind of go back
and forth
but with me when I'm this is how I serve
Twitter like you're watching live how I
served or listening if you're out there
listening on the directories which if
you don't listen to the directories you
should you should go over and download
each and every episode on Apple Spotify
Google
every single one of them and leave us a
review while you're there subscribing
so that you can listen to my voice not
just see my beautiful face but listen to
my voice this is the hottest show in
politics did you know that this is the
hottest [ __ ] show in politics and
it's gonna get hotter and hotter and
hotter baby
so don't stop watching and frankly
invite your friends your family your
community members to come here and watch
all your all the folks you got on
Facebook encourage them to come watch
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod you can follow me on Facebook that's
right I'm on Facebook we simulcast from
the Midas touch Facebook page but I'm on
Facebook
I also broadcast over there we started
broadcasting on my page so just search
the Tony Michaels or you can go to the
tonymichaels.com and follow me on all
the socials the instagrammies the tick
tocks
the tweets
and the books of face so go and you you
do you definitely want to subscribe to
the YouTube channel you don't want to
miss a YouTube channel I don't know if
you'd notice this but we've been posting
a ton of news Clips breaking news Clips
over here on the Tony Michaels podcast
we bring you those clips so that we can
hold media accountable and we can hold
these fascists accountable that's very
super important so don't forget to
follow us on all the platforms so you
don't miss a thing and spread us around
like herpes yeah spread is spread this
show around like herpes
foreign
let's see what what is this Mark Meadow
story Joyce Joyce has the scoop here
um this is good but also the notion that
there was ever every any question uh
ever any question that there's some
Special Rule
that lets people around Trump ignore
Federal grand jury subpoenas is lunacy
and so she's pointing this out now again
this is a CNN article but you know
sometimes CNN does the facts but we got
to keep them on track that's what I'm
saying we got to keep them on track we
got to hold them accountable so we can
get them corrected here and get them
away from this this bull sizing [ __ ]
because there is no both sides there's
not both sides to Federal subpoenas for
crimes there's not on both sides there
it's not
and that's what the Joyce is pointing
out here
that hey there's not two rules
there's not one rule for Trump and one
rule for everyone else that's not how it
works that's not how Justice works
that's not how the Department of Justice
works
so
[ __ ] them and Mark Meadows again he's
participating in subpoenas uh with the
Federal grand jury now we're assuming
that this Federal grand jury is
investigating not only the fake slate of
electors that they tried to stuff in the
box and get Mike Pence to declare Donald
Trump the winner with the fraudulent
electors because they weren't real I
mean of course everything everything
that has to do with Trump is [ __ ]
fake and [ __ ] [ __ ]
but they they stuff these boxes full of
these uh fake collectors and Mark
Meadows hey [ __ ] around and now he's
finding out now he's finding out with
Federal subpoenas and he's understanding
that oh well when there's an actual
Federal subpoena for crimes that I
committed that I can't just ignore them
oh Mark Meadows
you dumb [ __ ] okay let's see what else
do we have trending we're gonna have
Rachel bittickoffer on here just in a
minute now let's see what else do we
have what else do we have National
Archives oh yeah the records boy that's
heating up big time Big Time but the
thing I want to talk to Rachel about is
what we just witnessed that the
President Joe Biden dark Brandon came
out and he got this deal done for the
American people Joe Biden didn't deliver
this deal for himself he went out and
spoke about it for five minutes and half
the time he was giving credit to
everyone else
to everyone else can you imagine if
Trump would have to do this deal he
would have destroyed the railroads for
months he would have let them shut down
he would have [ __ ] destroyed the
American economy and then when he
finally reached a deal that he could
have reached if he did his [ __ ] job
then what he would do is take credit for
all of it Joe Biden didn't do any of
that he [ __ ] did the deal he got the
deal done for the American people to
keep the railroads open so our economy
would keep on track pun intended would
keep on track and he gave the credit to
the people who did the [ __ ] work
and that is why we need to choose
democracy over autocracy and Rachel Dr
Rachel bittickoffer
is going to talk about this as soon as
we come back so don't go anywhere Dr
Raider benicoffer as soon as we return
right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
foreign
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking to the break
you're not gonna be disappointed we got
Dr Rachel bidikoffer my favorite
political strategist number one number
one no question Rachel bittickoffer is
the number one political strategist in
the country she understands the issues
she understands what's going on Rachel
how are you
Tony oh well it does it does it
certainly it certainly does I'm I'm glad
to have you back here you've been so
busy fighting for democracy haven't you
I have been busy if I'm on the Tony
Michael show less that means it's good
yes that's right she's she's out there
fighting the good fight for all of us in
this democracy which we all should be
fighting for democracy in our own way
Rachel does it in her way I do it in my
way you should do it in yours whatever
way that is maybe it's the change in
your accounts that you give to a
campaign maybe you can make phone calls
text messages knock some doors whatever
it may be Rachel the thing I want to
talk about today is the contrast we have
in the country this morning we're
watching uh Rhonda santis be accused
of being a human trafficker which he is
not just accused he's admitted it right
out in the open Greg Abbott as well
that's their focus here is to ship
people from one state instead of doing
the hard work and figuring out how to
make these people an integral part of
their economy in their state they just
do the easy lazy thing and send them
somewhere else right
but Joe Biden does the hard work for the
American working people tell us about
this contrast I've been saying all
morning we got a message as contrast
it's not just giving the message about
what Joe Biden's doing and what Ron
DeSantis is doing give the American
people the choice do you want this
[ __ ] who's trafficking humans
lazily he's not working for those for
the Floridians and making sure those
people are put to work in the economy or
do you want the guy who's actually doing
something for the American economy I
mean that's why I really like Eric
swalwell's like frame and I'm sure he
just he's a lot like me he throws [ __ ]
out as it comes right and this this
hashtag may not have stuck out to him
but it stuck out to me and one day he
said lawmakers versus law Breakers right
and that's really what we have here I
mean especially with this contrast
between just CNS and Trump and Joe Biden
right I mean Joe Biden is a lawmaker the
Democratic party is working and getting
legislation through Congress and through
and signed into law that's affecting
everybody's lives livelihood Goods
um and you know on the other side all
they're interested in in is is a crime
right I mean it's a crime to get people
to push people into a situation where
they lose control of their own physical
placement right
um and traffic them I mean these people
are signing forms that are they speak
Spanish that are in English they have no
idea they're going to end up in
Massachusetts they're being separated
and family members are getting lost it's
it's uh yeah it's not cool
well I mean obviously the the
Republicans are and obviously doing
things that are not cool I mean
yesterday was it or the day before I
don't know I lose track so quickly these
fascists but Lindsey Graham gets out in
front of a microphone and gives us our
choice here's your choice you can vote
for republicans and we'll take away your
freedom or you can vote for Democrats
and they'll codify your freedom what do
you want what did you make of this
Lindsey Graham speech this dummy well
let me tell you guys this migrant
um you know shipping on migrants across
the country is is a the goal is like CRT
make us talk about it talk about how
immigration reform gets bogged out and
you know it's actually bogged down by
Republicans and the reason we have
Southern poor crises ongoing for 15
years so you really can't call it a
crisis is because the Republican Party
refuses absolutely [ __ ] refuses to
come to the table on comprehensive
immigration reform so that's what they
want us to do they want us to explain
all that have these long substantive
shows devoted to it and because and then
the reason why why they want us to do
that is that way we're not talking about
the fact that they're going to start our
women's fundamental Freedom across the
entire country from a National Abortion
man right so um so thank you for
bringing that back up and exactly right
we need to stay on message as tempting
as it is to get into these side debates
about migrants they understand that
politically the American population
might feel sympathy for migrants but
doesn't identify with them and that's a
very different thing because in group
and out grouping in terms of political
motivation and behavior is very very
important and they would love for us to
debate the merits of the immigration
system for the next month we're not
going to do that we're going to stay on
message and on focus and on attack every
time Republicans you know open their
mouths I want someone to remind the
voters of the Republican party on mass
is stripping women of their ability to
control their own livelihoods and bodies
so you know that's really what we want
to be you doing well I I I I agree
wholeheartedly for the we gotta press
that hey they're take they're gonna take
away your freedom Lindsey Graham's even
saying it he's saying he's going to take
away your freedom if you vote for him
and when this stuff comes up like Ron
DeSantis trafficking humans to
Massachusetts or Greg Abbott trafficking
humans to to Washington DC that the
thing that we need to do is put it in
contrast not have the big long argument
about why those people are human beings
they're [ __ ] human beings there's
your argument that's it they're human
beings and and this is this is the
contrast that you have you can either do
this or do this but I want to go back to
this this movement in registrations in
these states and back to what Lindsey
Graham even said and then uh also Jamie
Raskin went to the floor
um to to make this point is that they're
terrified of what happened in Kansas
they see what happened to Kansas and
they know that it's happening in
Michigan because the Michigan Supreme
Court did not play ball with these
fascists said no if they want to
referendum goddamn they can have it they
can decide whether they're going to have
[ __ ] freedoms or not and they're
terrified because they know people are
going to pick Freedom just like they did
in Kansas
yeah let me tell you I you know I'm
really worried about this in fact I'm
devoting my entire Twitter messaging and
strategy spaces tonight to the topic of
abortion messaging right because I want
to be sure people understand it is quite
possible like in Kansas yo those women
had gone into the ballot Booth with
other things on the ballot what we
almost certainly would have seen is the
abortion initiative uh failing by 60 you
know 60 whatever of a margin of 20
something points
um and then we would have seen those
same people who voted down the abortion
initiative voting for republicans and
the reason why guys is that if we don't
make it clear to women that Republicans
are the ones pushing these National
bands or these bands or Statewide
initiative Bands then people will not
make that connection we know that
because we can see that in pot data in
climate data right you have people who
are voting for these policies that don't
connect them clearly from A to B on the
parties and we need our messaging to
make that connection which is why
yesterday I was talking about look we've
been through seven election Cycles the
entire motivation or rationale behind
leaving your abortion messaging
non-partisan right like so in the case
of like Michigan they have an initiative
on the ballot and then they have these
competitive elections the case that has
been made for seven years is oh we gotta
don't say the word Republican you know
talk about just the initiative don't
connect it to the Republicans because we
need Republicans to vote for it and what
you end up doing in that case is you'll
you'll allow people to walk in there in
Michigan and vote for a initiative to
protect abortion Statewide and vote for
Republicans we gotta really make sure
people assign the villainous of this
policy the evilness of what drives the
mentality of policies like that with the
party that puts forth that kind of
legislation and I can't agree with you
more because Lindsey Graham did that
exactly the way that we need him to
um and he kind of walked into it but
Jamie ranskin had a great video that
came from the floor and I just want to
play a bit of it here real quick Rachel
um to show the viewers the very
beginning of it where he roast uh
Lindsey Graham so let's watch a bit of
this and then we'll talk about it on the
other side why is that well part of it
is because of the good people of Kansas
who showed them just where America is on
this America is a country committed to
individual freedom
and the rights of the people to make
their own decisions and not having Busy
Body theocrat politicians and state
capitals telling them how to make their
own decisions about their careers about
their lives about their families and
about their health care and certainly
not allowing Lindsey Graham to dictate
to the women of America what their
Destiny will be and they won't say a
word about it they'll talk about an SEC
regulation nobody heard of that we're
not here to talk about today
they'll blame Joe Biden for Global
inflation they'll blame Joe Biden for
Vladimir Putin's filthy imperialist
invasion of Russia I hear them
denouncing Joe Biden they won't denounce
Vladimir Putin for one second I'd
happily yield a minute if they would
denounce
Vladimir Putin but they won't do it and
we've heard people over on their side
cheerleading for Vladimir Putin I heard
the gentlelady from Georgia say Russia
wins guess what Russia doesn't win
Rachel the best Jamie Raskin the best
Jamie ranskin is this Jamie ranskin
it is you know I mean you know him Tim
Ryan Eric sawwell and um you know over
in the Senate Chris Murphy are you know
three or four of the best Messengers the
party has because they're they are
willing to call Republicans out writ
large this is a party that has collapsed
into extremism and you know I appreciate
that that for the White House's purposes
I mean you have Joe Biden I tweeted
um uh after his big prime time speech
last week I tweeted listen it's it you
have an easier time getting called an
[ __ ] by Elmo I mean called a fascist
by Joe Biden okay and the reason I
tweeted that I mean it's funny and
whatever but it's it's so true Joe Biden
temperamentally is not the kind of I
mean ideologically temperamentally you
know not an alarmist at all so if he's
talking about a fascist threat that I
mean that's [ __ ] huge right right
and you know you know I appreciate that
for for his for the White House's
purposes of getting Biden comfortable
that there has to be rhetorically a
degree of separation for him between the
Old Republic and party and what they've
defined as Maga extremists okay now our
job I mean certainly the job I think
needs to happen for this you know
democracy is taking to win elections is
to to writ large make sure people
understand no no you're Republican too
oh yeah that guy that you think you like
he's a nut too all right and if he's not
you know mouth foaming like obvious not
he votes with those nuts every [ __ ]
time they ask him to vote so he will
come for you right and like um you know
so I'm really urging people tonight in
this in the spaces and uh you know
beyond that you have to make the villain
be the Republican party and we can't be
uh allowing Republicans a distance of
Separation aside from the rhetoric that
comes you know top down from the White
House and again that's about you know
who Joe Biden is as a person he's not
comfortable I'm sure with a broad brush
but we need to be paying that Rob Rush
right right I I think I think you're
right I mean you talk about uh these
people voting in the way of taking away
your freedom and the Republicans even
understand this you've seen Blake
Masters and other uh these candidates
scrub this their actual anti-woman
rhetoric off their websites
um even Jesse water gets Waters gets it
here on Fox News he tells Lindsey Graham
here hey you messed up by saying this
listen this quick second I know and
North Korea we all agree on that no wait
a minute now listen I'm not going to sit
on the sidelines and let America become
that kind of nation no one's saying you
need to sit on the sidelines but
yesterday wasn't the day to do that yes
sir so there's there's Jesse Waters and
knowing exactly what Lindsey Graham did
he [ __ ] up he [ __ ] up and they gave
he gave Democrats another tool now I
know maybe Lindsay's working hard for
Democrats I seriously doubt it um but he
definitely is doing the work that that
needs to be done and that is to show the
American people exactly who they are
yeah I mean you know the gift that keeps
on getting here's what I think motivated
Lindsey Graham I think frustration that
McConnell is not going to be the Senate
Majority Leader that they're not going
to win the Senate that they're being
direct I mean his mind he's a he's a
victim not a participant right they're
being dragged down by Mago Republicans
even though Lindsey Graham has done more
than any single person except for Paul
Ryan to legitimate the Maga wing of the
party right and so
um you know I think what he he was
honestly thinking I think is oh well if
we ban abortion at 15 weeks that's gonna
and anybody who knows anything about
abortion will tell you that's like 94 of
all abortions that occur in the U.S now
being legalized okay and Graham was
thinking you know this will help us with
swing voters in Suburbia but actually
like in the old world it might have
because our party might have been dumb
enough to debate the merits of what he's
arguing but you know all that matters to
me is Lindsey Graham has proposed a
National Abortion ban okay and that's
how I will refer to it okay I'm not
going to call it uh abortion being at 15
weeks or this or that or whatever I'm
not gonna do any of his [ __ ] work for
him but I will take the federal abortion
ban component of his legislation and
Define the entire Republican party's
Congressional cycle upon it
you know this is good points to where
you don't get in the Weeds on this stuff
and I've said this so many times stop
talking about statistics stop talking
about line items and bills get at the
heart of this get at the simple parts of
this and get at the messaging of this
and you know I don't know if if Eric
swalwell's campaign listens to my show I
don't know if they do I I seriously
doubt that there's someone over there
listening to it but he put out this ad
and it actually proves to me that me and
and Dr Rachel over here have been
yelling and screaming about messaging
since February or March on this show and
it feels like Rachel that everyone now
in the pro-democracy camp is on the same
page because I want to show you this ad
from Eric swalwell and the audience
listen to the language in here you're
gonna notice I don't know if they came
and copied and I don't mind if Eric
swallowed or any campaign wants to come
and copy the language here or the
messaging here you're more than welcome
to take it steal it put it in political
ads but listen to the messaging here
he's spot on you know what's on the
ballot
it's not just legislation and policies
we believe in it's democracy our
democracy there's a choice on the ballot
between freedom and fear between cruelty
and compassion between chaos and
Community between voting or violence and
the end of Rights Generations have
fought for the extremist separate plan a
road map for a nation where your voice
is silenced and your vote is a memory
where they Count Their votes and cast
ours aside that's why this year this
fight this vote is so important
register engage volunteer fight back
against the disinformation it was fair
and most of all vote because your vote
it's all that stands between our future
and theirs
oh Eric swallows after my heart with
this Rachel
yeah I mean
I mean from the length you could have
thought I wrote that ad I mean
for a client I mean well but I think
that's the point that I was trying to
make earlier is that everyone seems to
be on messaging even though even though
we're not all coordinating at this point
it really is oh yeah you're exactly
right I mean there's so much reform like
fuel now that is burning on its own
right and like you know not yeah
certainly I'm not I have no affiliation
with the Smallville ad in any way
um you know 30 seconds you'll know it's
me when it's 30 seconds number one
and uh you know I love the front end of
that ad it actually siphons off quite
nicely and I think that's where it
should stop right there violence or
whatever voting or violence is the last
line and then you know you throw that
[ __ ] on there why do I think that
because the people who need to watch
political advertising will never watch a
minute-long [ __ ] ad okay so just
because you like it and watch it doesn't
mean that the people who need this
messaging will ever [ __ ] look at it
and watch it and that's why I front end
all my [ __ ] 30 seconds and the most
important thing I want to convey gets
done in the first five
right well and I think that's a great
point and you've been doing these
Twitter spaces I've been trying to join
you when I can on Thursdays um to talk
about messaging because you are so
goddamn good at it that's why I believe
you are the the number one the goat when
it comes to political strategy on the
pro-democracy side and you're my
favorite political Strat I just don't
say that uh to uh to get your feels up I
don't just say that to get your feels up
I truly believe that because you are you
do uh we get along so well because we
talk alike so much um but you gotta come
join Rachel at these Twitter spaces with
the messaging because she's not only
talking about National messaging but
people are able to ask her questions and
you're able to ask her questions about
what you should be doing because I think
that's most important I try to talk
about that on the show it's not just
important that we have this National
message like the swalwell ad head but
it's so important for everyone to know
their to know what they need to do to
engage age in democracy and that is the
most important so tell us about these
Twitter spaces and what you're trying to
do over there yeah I mean and in terms
of like activists like I mean that's
that's the thing I want people to
understand is that every single person
with six followers is an influencer if
they choose to be and they recognize
that role right so like you and I since
we first met our first conversations was
about you know we got to push the
progressive you know Community to talk
about Republicans and not to stay
focused on Democrats because most of the
conversations interest vote perspective
and not you know focused on on the
opposition and defining why we don't
have nice [ __ ] right so um you know the
reason I like after this is because you
know one if you change one person's
conversation get them to stop using Maga
and use Republican because nobody
recognizes Maga okay like um GOP is not
Name ID at 100 either right so if you
want people to know you're talking about
Republicans you really gotta spoon feed
it even though it's eight word letters
or very wordy right
um and uh getting I mean if we if we can
optimize people at the individual level
and
some of the people coming on the culture
consultants and and others right but a
lot of them are activists or especially
running Grassroots activist groups it
and if we can get our rhetoric focused
on not taking the bait so not spending
three days talking about immigration
when we should be talking about National
Abortion bans
um and then using the right rhetoric
when they do so so that we're not just
making [ __ ] popular or connecting that
popular [ __ ] to voting for Democrats and
against Republicans that really can make
a difference and I know it for a fact
because just in in a few months we've
got so much of this system that's homing
now I'm certainly not the only person
working on it or trying to reform it so
I don't want to make it sound like I I'm
saying hey I look what we've done I've
done uh but we together the reformist
part of the party has really made
tremendous gains in the messaging and
we're seeing the advance
um we're seeing how that's playing out
to our advantage I want to be clear we
could be doing everything that we've
done up to this point me and everybody
else who's working with or without me on
this reform stuff and we would not be in
the position we're in right now without
Roe being eviscerated period end of
story fact okay but because where it was
eviscerated and because we've performed
the messaging together these two things
could give us the house okay and so it's
really important for people to be
hammering the Republicans hyperbolic
messaging don't have to be technical
we're not trying to win accuracy things
or Politico okay just make ads about how
the Republican party wants to put in a
national work abortion ban you don't
have to describe it you know
keep it simple stupid right that's how
we want to think about our messaging
well I think that's I think that's great
and and I I encourage everyone out there
listening to not only go follow Dr
Rachel bittickoff or on Twitter at
Rachel it's at Rachel bidikoffer um and
I'll put it I've got it here somewhere
there it is at Rachel
um bit of golfer so go follow her on
Twitter but also don't forget because on
Thursday night she does these Twitter
spaces and you guys can go ask her a
question if you want you just get on
Twitter you go to spaces I know it's uh
spaces is still kind of new and people
are still learning but Rachel is a
really unique way for for people to ask
you questions about what they're saying
to their their community members their
family their friends their Church
parishioners the people at the PTA hell
the people at the grocery store line
um it's really important so tell us what
time then happens and and plug anything
else that you'd like yeah I mean we're
doing those on Thursdays right now at 6
00 p.m Eastern 3 P.M Pacific all you got
to do is go on the spaces icon on your
Twitter and it will pop up a list of the
current spaces being offered the message
matters is mine
um and you
um you know get just you can drop in for
a little bit for the whole hour you can
submit questions you can speak or you
can just listen right
um but yeah it's it's actually coming it
was kind of spontaneous it wasn't like
we were planning we just did one and it
was so fruitful for people to get
feedback
um that we decided to just run them
through the cycle
well I think it's a great idea and
everyone
um go go listen to Rachel maybe not the
whole hour what's that I'm sorry can I
say one thing I just forgot tonight I've
decided to start bringing in some other
strategists and and whatever with me I
mean kind of for everything I do is
half-assed that's not directly moving
voters to the polls and for us right I
try to keep the public facing [ __ ] going
but I just don't I don't have time to do
heavily produce things so I'm here to
tell you tonight Dan in in Kona from way
to win action fund will be my guest
we're going to be talking about how he's
they have an intensive research shop at
way to win it's one of my favorite
organizations
um and they did extensive ad testing in
2020 which is how I know these
bipartisan messages I'm going to work
with everybody I'm gonna get [ __ ] done
lost us 14 House Seats cycle right
because it's just not we want people to
think and feel like that that's not how
people think and feel okay and and uh
anyway we don't want to win is doing
some incredible like message testing
work and he's gonna be talking about
what they've found in some of that
extensive testing and uh also talk a
little bit about how we're trying to
broaden out the row issue and making
about values right a choice it sounds
like you're going to a drive-through or
picking a movie okay what we really want
to do is make people understand the
totality of and the severity of what
that choice entails that choice is our
freedom right and so we're going to talk
about how an abortion ads we're working
to really values up our rhetoric and uh
that will that will be exciting I hope
to see you guys there tonight
everyone go join Rachel bitcover on
Twitter just go to her profile at that
time and just go to Rachel bittickoffer
it'll give you a little it looked like a
weird white thing around the the profile
and you can just click on that and it'll
take you straight to the spaces that
she's talking in the one that she is in
you just go to her profile at that time
at Rachel click follow first of all
don't don't leave the Bro Von go to the
space without following because as
Rachel says copy her tweets copy her
messaging go out there and push this
stuff get in the threads and get this
stuff out to the people because if we
get the right messaging to all the
people that are pro-democracy that are
here to save our way of life and not dip
us into a fascist State we can do this
together we can do this together Rachel
thanks for joining us
Let's go Team D I'll see you guys next
time we'll see you soon Rachel everyone
stick around we'll be right back right
after this break thank you Rachel
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show Dr Rachel
whittakoffer go over there I'm telling
you
on the Twitter spaces tonight even if
you don't catch all of it
definitely go over
and take a listen to just a few minutes
five ten minutes you'll probably stick
around for the whole damn thing oh I
still have Rachel's thing up here well
again while I still have everything up
here here's her handle at Rachel
bittickoffer well I still have it up
here on the screen so go follow her on
Twitter and you can watch her spaces
tonight on Twitter don't forget to go
listen in on that spaces it's fantastic
again you can the spaces is evolving
over on Twitter it's still kind of new
they're still working out a few of the
Kinks but really um you can go over you
can just listen you can just join in and
you can hear everyone speaking uh you
can request to talk you just push the
little request button down below
um they'll try to put you in line so
that you can ask Rachel a question or
ask the other strategist a question if
you have a question for the other
speakers and I I've been in the room too
they've had me as a speaker in there as
well now for messaging but you can also
you can you can submit questions
um in the comments they got a little
comment thing down there you can submit
questions or you can just take a listen
Maybe people are asking the questions
that you want to to know anyways that's
probably the likely case is they're
wanting you're they're asking the
questions that you want to know
um so go take a listen again that's
every Thursday six o'clock Eastern on
Twitter spaces just go to Rachel's
profile at that time and click on her
profile picture it's got a little white
circle with a microphone on it that
indicates that she's in that space
that's how you can find her space at
that time that's the easiest way to get
to her spaces to go to her profile and
click on her profile picture at that
time so make sure to go listen over
there it's a highly interesting I
stumbled across it several weeks ago and
I went into the room and and then I've
been listening every week since uh just
just to get some of this messaging out
there to the folks and not only that but
I wanted to see what people were asking
like the questions that folks were
asking
um to Rachel about messaging about the
things that they're struggling with out
there for messaging and that's why I
want you to watch this show every single
week day Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific is because
we try to answer those questions here we
try to give you the stuff that's the
most important things we try to make
sure that we hold these fascists
accountable we want you to know the plan
like Eric swalwell says that they're
trying to create they're saying it out
loud they want a fascist State and if
you know these things you're armed with
these with these politicized facts yes
they are politicized this rhetoric as as
Rachel says these are not bad words
folks rhetoric and politicizing rhetoric
will save our democracy I know it you
know like ooh gross let's get no it is
not gross this is how politics work this
is how it works that's why I say always
there's two things at play here there
was government
which is lawmakers and administrative
officials doing the job of setting
policy determining policy
that's the thing that we want them to do
but to do that we have to do the other
thing which is elections we have to play
the politics because if we don't win
elections we don't get the set policy
and by we I mean pro-democracy folks
that's what I mean and right now
unfortunately in this country we only
have one party one part and I do say
unfortunately I wish the Republican
Party actually believed in democracy I
wish they did not want to drive us into
a fascist state it would be much easier
to protect democracy if both parties
were on board to have a democracy and to
and to actually save it and for people's
Liberty for their rights for their
freedoms but we don't we do not have
that Lindsey Graham
came out in front of a microphone and
said I want to have a National Abortion
ban just elect Republicans and we'll
take your freedom away if you elect
Democrats they'll protect your freedoms
so vote Republican if you wanted your
Freedom's taken away so go tell your
[ __ ] neighbors go tell your friends
go tell the people at the PTA your
fellow parishioners at church tell them
the Republicans are saying it out loud
they want to take your freedoms away and
if you think it's just going to stop at
a National Abortion ban get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
they are not going to stop and the
National Abortion ban they're going to
continue barrel down this road of
fascism
they're going to do it they're not going
to stop they say oh we just need to
overturn Roe we wait and everything will
be great and we just leave it up to the
states and like Rachel said now that
they know that the people in the states
will say [ __ ] you you're not taking away
our freedoms now they're like nope the
states doesn't have the rights anymore
[ __ ] you if we gave you the right to
take away people's rights and you won't
do that now we're going to take you
right away and we're going to take away
everyone's Freedom that's what they're
saying folks that's what they're saying
so get it straight in your messaging
stop talking about you know little
little side facts and details [ __ ] that
[ __ ] it's time to win it's time to win
democracy it's time to put adults in
charge who want to set policy for the
American working people
for the American working class
for the Americans the people who are
here and I'm not just talking about
citizens I'm talking about everyone here
who is working hard for their way of
life
and the Republicans want to take it away
from you that's what they want to do and
I love this ad by Eric swallow I'm glad
I played it with Rachel bittickoffer and
I watched this this morning I guess he
released it yesterday but doesn't it
seem I don't know it just seems like
maybe there's someone here listening
from Eric swallow's campaign and I'm I I
really don't mind if they steal my
rhetoric I actually encourage it just
like Rachel says yeah steal my Riddick
[ __ ] yeah hell yeah steal my rhetoric go
out there and and talk exactly the way
I'm talking hell to the yeah but you
notice there was a few key phrases in
there that are ringing true and folks I
don't actually think that Eric's one of
Eric swallows campaign people or what
maybe they are but
here's the point is that we're getting
on track with messaging Democrats are
all on the same page of democracy and
we're not doing the stupid [ __ ] that
we've always done before which is
getting the Weeds about dumb [ __ ] that
distracts from the actual conversation
which is do you want freedom or do you
not want freedom that's your choice
autocracy or democracy which do you want
which is it do you want to have a say or
do you not want to have a say
that's your choice here
and we're all on the same page and it's
happening it's working it's [ __ ]
working it's beautiful and the other
thing too that we have is we have actual
we have actual lawmakers and
administration officials who are out
doing the work for the American people
which makes it easy for us to continue
the messaging
and to continue the rhetoric to continue
politicizing things for them so they
don't have to we shouldn't rely on our
lawmakers to politicize everything we
should be doing it us pro-democracy
people should be politicizing this [ __ ]
out of every damn thing and let them set
the policy that's the point that's how
it's supposed to work that's what the
Republicans have always understood and
they forgot about it under Trump they
completely forget about it completely
forget he dumbed them down so much that
they're losing their [ __ ] party
they're in disarray they don't even have
a party anymore
like Rachel says you got to call them
Republicans
you don't want to you want to call Mega
Republicans and they are
they're fascist but listen
we have to get on message and we're
getting there oh baby are we getting
there we only got two months left
and just as I say as always this is the
most important election of Our
democracy's Lifetime right now because
it is do or die here for our democracy
and as soon as it's over as soon as it's
over the votes are counted certified and
Democrats have big huge gains and big
huge wins which I know we will because
you people are out there and you are
working hard
then the next election is the most
important election of our democracy's
lifetime
the most important so don't forget that
keep that in mind keep that in the
Forefront you have to politicize
everything every [ __ ] thing
and I know it gets tired of talking
about this stuff but if we get tired if
we get if we go to sleep
and we just let them take over
you won't have a voice you won't have a
vote you won't have freedoms that's the
point that's why they're working so hard
to take them away from you because they
know that so let's get back to the
tweets and trendy Trends here let's see
what else do we have trending now is
there anything new going on we got about
20 minutes left in the show we're 40
minutes into the second hour
here tomorrow is bone end of the week
again Gabe didn't join us today and he
won't be with us tomorrow live but he is
going to be on he is going to be on the
episode we recorded bone end of the week
so don't forget to follow And subscribe
here on the Tony Michaels podcast you
don't want to miss bonehead tomorrow in
the second hour on Friday because we air
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and the
books of face
so follow us everywhere also follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod
you can go look at the poll you can
actually still vote on the poll on
YouTube
um but we've already recorded So the
results are the results are in we
stopped the count
as it were
maybe we'll stop the steel I don't know
I don't know but you can also watch here
the other thing about bone of the week
tomorrow
you can watch bonehead of the week live
on the Tony Michaels podcast in the
second hour every Friday or you can
catch the replay on the Midas touch
Network YouTube channel it replays over
there on the Midas Touch YouTube channel
at eight Eastern every single Friday on
a replay you can go watch that over
there too and download every single
episode we actually put bonehead of the
week on the directory so you can
download bonehead because it's our
favorite it's our favorite segment
you can go download it on Sundays on
Apple Spotify Google make sure to leave
us a great review while you're
subscribing and downloading bonehead of
the week there download every single
episode frankly now let's see what else
do we have trending here again you you
it's still trending and do you president
X is there anyone what the hell that
means
Don Lemon is still trending oh what else
do we have here the governors is still
trending yeah they're still going to
talk about this human trafficking thing
and again don't get too in the weeds but
draw a contrast oh Chrissy alley is
trending you gotta see this
you gotta see this stupid [ __ ] I'm not
kidding you look at this Idiot Nick
Adams you ever seen this Nazi on here he
says the dumbest [ __ ] he's a verified
account but you would think that this is
all satire and parody as dumb as these
tweets are listen to this listen to this
dumb [ __ ] Hollywood needs more actresses
like Chrissy alley Christy Allen excuse
me I don't even know her name that's how
forgotten she is uh like Christy alley
and few are like Meryl Streep get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] who
actually believes this nonsense
I mean you know you can like
Chrissy Christy alley and you can like
Meryl Streep but who actually believes
that this weirdo cue in honor she's in
two Cults did you know that she's a q a
r and she's Scientology which you know
it's not too far-fetched for
a delusional person that believes [ __ ]
like Scientology to believe stupid
delusional [ __ ] like Q Anon but this
chewing on my idiot Kirstie Alley this
Trump Pumper
is better than Meryl Streep Christy
alley lost her career a long time ago
before she became a q anoner
she's a she's washed up she is washed up
here's what I said about this tweet I
just want to make it clear because again
this goes back this goes back to
messaging now there might be a a
misspelling in this tweet or two yeah I
I have a lot of misspellings in my
tweaks but I really don't have any
regrets so I don't delete stuff and then
try to repost it I said
I told Nick I said Nick look you
preferring Chrissy alley over Meryl
Streep is why flies prefer [ __ ] over
honey you are a dumb son of a [ __ ] and
I'm gonna make sure he knows his tweet
sucks your Tweet sucks Nick it's
horrible and this is the kind of [ __ ]
that we have to deal with
is people out there saying delusional
stupid [ __ ] like this objectively
objectively Meryl Streep is a way better
actor than Christy alley objectively
I mean she certainly is it's provable
like you can just look at the awards and
the [ __ ] art she's done versus what
Christie alley
hasn't done in a long time because it
sucks to suck so
whoosh Nick Adams what a bonehead
[ __ ] bonehead I'm speaking of
boneheads I actually before we go
because we got about 15 minutes left
here in the show
um
let's see
oh this is yeah here we go Rand Paul did
you guys watch the video yesterday of
Rand ball getting schooled by Dr fauci
oh my God Dr fauci dunked him in the
[ __ ] trash but here he appears on
Sean Hannity because that's what his
talking points were
Rand Paul put on this big production in
the senate committee hearing where he he
gets to question
Dr fauci okay he can ask real [ __ ]
questions real questions that the
American people want to know or he can
do stupid performance art political
performance art so that he can appear on
Sean Hannity's show that's exactly what
he did because he knew that uh Sean
Hannity it wouldn't be surprising if
there was text between Sean Hannity Rand
ball you know a seditious sext messages
I'm talking about how oh yeah you should
really say this and you should say that
and I'll play it on my show you know
coordinating into the senate committee
hearing so that way they can have this
political theater of course Dr fancy has
none of it and dunks him in the trash
but here is Rand Paul on Fox News
talking to Sean Hannity about him being
a dumb [ __ ] listen to this stupid [ __ ]
did you ever get any vaccine if you you
don't have to answer if you don't want
obviously no I didn't but I want people
to be clear he most certainly did
yes I'm saying it Rand Paul is [ __ ]
vaccinated Hondo pursinto I don't doubt
it for a minute you know why because he
says he didn't because he knows that his
little [ __ ] his little fandom that he
has his little fouchy fandom that he has
they're [ __ ] obsessed they are Rand
Paul fans are obsessed with Anthony
valje I mean absolutely obsessed
everyone says that that the Liberals
have Trump derangements under him Jesus
Christ go go look at the fandom that
Rand Paul has I mean they think like Dr
fauci is some kind of like
I don't know cyborg or some [ __ ] it's
really weird stuff but listen to what
the guy who's lying about being
vaccinated here has to say about his
about his wife listen to this clear I'm
not against taking the vaccine for my
in-laws who are 91 and 86 we recommended
we got them first in line uh my wife
ended up getting vaccinated even though
she has no health problems is thin and
about the same age as I am
she's thin I don't know what the hell
that means
what does that mean I guess he's saying
fat people should be vaccinated is that
what he's saying
I I think that's what he's saying as if
like like thin people don't get the
coronavirus I'm not sure what the [ __ ]
he's talking about like I mean I mean
overweight people generally have
co-orbids right because they have health
problems diabetes heart disease because
some overweight people have those
problems
but is he is he saying that then people
don't have comorbids what a dumb
[ __ ] man this just proves just
in this little [ __ ] 20 seconds here
that Rand Paul is full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
actually he does he does know what he's
talking about he does know what he's
doing he's lying to all the fandom he's
built this fandom on hating bauchi and
he can't undo it he has to placate into
it that's why they're so [ __ ] trapped
here they're trapped
in fascism they're trapped in it because
they [ __ ] they cozied up to it for so
goddamn long
they cozied up to it and now they're
gonna pay the price because you are
gonna make them pay the price
with democracy in the vote and the
ballot [ __ ] them uh so I wanted to show
you that piece of information the other
thing too
that's happening is some news this
morning Kyle Chaney had it here says
just end the January 6 committee is
seeking another 32 pages of John
Eastman's emails telling a federal judge
that it needs them to quote complete its
efforts including preparation of final
report
um so they're going to get more of John
Eastman's emails here to give to the
public so the public is actually gonna
in a final report looks like the
Public's gonna see exactly what John
Eastman was planning more what he was
planning in more detail from his emails
which is big news the other big news is
that in some of these cases around
surrounding surrounding the former guy
is apparently the doj is requested to
file the motion uh to release and unseal
the uh closed caption or excuse me the
closed circuit the security footage from
Mar-A-Lago which is super important
um and this is all going to really play
out very well in pro-democracy's favor
this is what democracy and Justice does
is it it eventually comes and gets you
when when you're when you're when you're
tuckered up with with lies and not the
truth it it really it you [ __ ] around
you find out speaking of [ __ ] around
it and finding out here is uh Mike
Lindell talking to Eric Bowlin bowling
on the Newsmax
oh my God the my pillow guy Jesus
[ __ ] Christ this mustache Mussolini
good Lord
this guy can't get any [ __ ] Dumber
listen to what he says about his cell
phone here and what's on his cell phone
listen to this dumb [ __ ] Amendment case
against the FBI I'm not sure what
they're going to find on your phone but
but forgot something they're going to
find out then they're going to find a
they're going to find a lot of promo
codes for a lot of products
so when the news max has been great by
the way
thank you thank you oh my God so the guy
can't help but pimp in his products
because he's [ __ ] broke because he
spent all this money to try to overturn
our elections and committed [ __ ] God
knows how many [ __ ] felonies he's
committed by this point trying to steal
[ __ ] voting records off voting
machines the exact thing he's accusing
Democrats are doing like literally
they're saying they tampered with the
minion voting machines and we can prove
it because we tampered with them and
then once we got the [ __ ] we tampered
with it doesn't show what we're saying
it's really [ __ ] dumb and by him
saying again here I'll back it up listen
to the very first part listen to this
system in case against the FBI I'm not
sure what they're going to find on your
phone but but
they're gonna find a lot of [ __ ] on his
phone a ton of [ __ ] on his phone he said
he said when they took it I run all my
businesses from that phone all of them
so if any of these businesses have
anything to do and he's using his
businesses even the [ __ ] commit
crimes this guy is completely [ __ ] the
other thing too is is saying this what
kind of what I mean I don't know what he
orders at Hardee's what kind of porn do
you think this guy watches I'm just
saying I'm I'm not I don't know anything
but what it you look at him what do you
think it is that's that's all I'm saying
um the mustache you know might
give something away now let's see what
else what else do we have here on the
list uh from uh
that we can show you Pro democracy
people we got uh eight minutes left here
left in the hour let's see if I can find
another uh piece of footage here uh for
the for the great people out there
um I thought I had something here
I know I did Maybe not maybe not I
it happens
it had oh yes yes this is one thing I
wanted to show
here you go
uh this is Dr Rachel bidikovver again
this is where you go follow her at
Rachel bittickoffer on Twitter to find
her spaces and again when the spaces
comes up it'll have like this little
icon over her
over her her profile picture here
but she tweets this about the Amtrak or
the railroad uh strike this morning and
here is here's the messaging again all
you have to do is Select this copy and
paste this
and then you can even steal her image
here here's the image Democrats deliver
you can steal this image from her even
she doesn't care that's why she's got it
there she wants you to steal her
messaging she wants you to steal her
tweets she gives you permission I know
she said this out loud but she tweets
this this morning Amtrak Joe helped
Foster a railroad deal at 2 30 a.m last
night to prevent a catastrophic Railroad
Strike
see that she's not getting into the
weeds she's not talking about the deal
what it entails how when it happens you
know all that [ __ ] you don't need to
do that you just need to say the fact
and what it is and get it going so
there's Rachel bittickoffers tweet again
go follow Dr Rachel biddergover on
Twitter and not only that come tonight
at six Eastern
on um on on Spaces on Twitter
again you just go to her profile and
when you come here again on this profile
picture here there'll be a little circle
around it that indicates that she's in
that space you just click that
[ __ ] it'll take you straight
there and you can you can ask Rachel
bidicoff for a question all you got to
do is just request the microphone and
then you can you can chime in and ask
Rachel any question that you would like
um there on the Twitter spaces that way
you have the ability to stay in touch
now with with these people here is uh
David Wade I want to go back to our
title here real quick before we leave uh
yes this is the story from Ron DeSantis
new we can confirm 50 migrants were
flown to Martha's Vineyard
and are being helped at a church the men
women and kids that's right they're men
women and children he's a child
trafficker and didn't know where they
were and Florida coming around to
Santa's told Fox News he sent them as
part of his relocation program for
illegal immigrants he's such a [ __ ]
idiot
so he's admitting that he's a child
trafficker like they're like oh save the
children we need to stop at the blood
second ball from trafficking these
children and the people they're voting
for the people who are saying that [ __ ]
are actually they're they're actually in
real life
trafficking children
across state lines across borders
that's what they're doing sending them
places
they don't even know where they're going
are you following me they're trafficking
children
it's really not complicated especially
when you put it in stark contrast today
Ron DeSantis is trafficking children Joe
Biden is getting the American working
people back to work on the railroads
making sure our economy is open and
strong simple messaging not in the weeds
not on the [ __ ]
simple [ __ ] that's what you got to do
that's how you tweet it too
oh my God
this is hilarious
uh you guys know Roy Wood Jr this might
get I'm gonna play this this is [ __ ]
great this might this has to do with
Hardee's and Mike Lindell
um this might
this might get to silence because I
don't know if it's Roy's video or if
it's The Daily Show video but so if
you're watching on YouTube and you're
wondering why you can't hear those
videos because YouTube is has made me
cut it out
um because of uh copyright [ __ ] but uh
Roy this is great this is great video
watch that pillow dude Mike Lindell got
the FBI and he took his phone but I just
wanted to say something real quick uh to
the FBI you don't
you don't arrest nobody at Hardee's man
let them finish that biscuit Hardy's is
too delicious to be could you imagine me
in
detained by authorities while your
delicious hearties biscuit
it's just getting cold you don't do that
like if it was a Popeye's biscuit I take
him into custody he might jump to death
and die and you don't get no testimony
but this is Hardee's dog you're just a
certain biscuits in the game you let a
man finish his biscuit before you take
him into custody
Red Lobster cheddar baked biscuits in
the three main biscuits that if you and
I don't care what the crime is you let a
man
hey
this ain't no Olive Garden unlimited
breadstick take him into custody heating
Olive Garden take them down Olive Garden
don't even believe in a breadsticks
that's why they're unlimited because
they just won't they want to get rid of
them
ain't no unlimited Hardy's biscuit you
want another one you gotta pay
McDonald's biscuit take them down
take them down but not Hardies Hardee's
has worked too hard to be famous for one
thing Hardy's open 24 hours a day The
Only Thing Worth eating they serve in a
full hour window you wouldn't let that
man finish that
foreign
oh my God you know um
speaking of Hardee's and the incident
that happened at Hardee's
um I I gotta show you guys this this is
fantastic Gabe Sanchez actually sent
this to me this morning Hardee's just
chimed in on this and we were waiting to
see if Hardy's would chime in on this um
where the FBI had seized Mike Lindell
the Mike pelegay's phone the CEO of my
Billow and she's just phone in a
Hardee's drive-through here is here's
the tweet from Hardee's
um this morning
oh you talking about cold-blooded now
Hardy says if you still have a phone get
uh if you still have a phone get a free
breakfast biscuit in our app for our
rewards members and they give you a link
there where you can get a free breakfast
biscuit again you still you gotta have a
phone to get this so Hardy's with the
sweet burn on the My Pillow guy uh doing
the work for democracy this is [ __ ]
hilarious
hilarious this is Holy actual [ __ ] uh
Hardy's these fast food restaurants they
do not they're not disappoint with their
Twitter accounts everyone
thanks for joining us today again come
tomorrow on YouTube Twitter and twitch
and simoncasting from the Facebook page
as we do every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific tomorrow's Friday we do bone end
of the week in the second hour it's
pre-recorded tomorrow but we have it for
you tomorrow bone end of the week and
speaking of that don't forget to go
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod where you can vote for bone of the
week you can vote on YouTube too but
follow us on Twitter and download every
single episode Apple Spotify Google
leave us a review while you're
subscribing to the Tony Michaels podcast
on your favorite directory and don't
forget don't forget
we have to support pro-democracy speech
and if you want to support the show we
love that we love that you support the
show you can do a couple different
things you can go over to the merch
store you can get dark Brandon t-shirt
or your hoodie coffee mug or a sticker
just go to store.thetonymichaels.com
pick up your exclusive the Tony Michaels
podcast dark Brandon design there
or you know you can actually give to the
show if you want there's a support link
down below
support.tonymichaelspod.com there's a QR
code there in the corner you can call
you can take a picture of that and go
give us support there or you can just
spread this around show it to your
friends your family members give us a
retweet give us a like come subscribe
go to the tonymichaels.com and go
subscribe to all the channels do us a
favor support bro democracy speech and
not just our speech support everyone's
pro-democracy speech out there go
tonight tonight on Twitter spaces and go
listen to this this spaces on messaging
that Dr Rachel bittickoffer does don't
forget to go do that tonight as well
everyone
same time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon